foreign
[Music]
I told you not to do that leave me be
I'm working on something Tommy it's bad
for you
[Laughter]
thank you
no no no no no
all right
[Music]
are you okay okay I heard you broke a
mug no I didn't break a mug okay so one
of you is gonna pay for that I was
attacked by Tommy welcome back to the
break room everybody uh it's a very
special werewolf By Night episode oh
baby really nice guys I was excited I
didn't know I didn't know and I didn't
think about it and I I should have
confirmed with you guys that we were
doing a werewolf by night thing and
you're you're dressed as crinkle cut the
sassy cat uh I I came dressed as Mr
Mistoffelees I thought we were doing a
Broadway theme today but oh no no no no
no it's werewolf By Night day that's
right and uh no we said we're doing a
broad topic right yeah we're doing it in
the broadest way possible uh but welcome
we hope everybody had a chance to watch
werewolf by night last night I know it
came out late but maybe today we stayed
up we've all seen it right now if not
you can watch it instead of this no go
ahead sorry but hit the like button
before you go yes hit like And subscribe
uh and then leave and then come back but
also I mean we are gonna talk about it a
lot it's not the kind of spoilery kind
of a Content sort of you haven't seen it
yet you can still listen to us talk
about it we're not going to ruin it for
you I don't think
um Tommy's gonna speak about it as uh as
you would a relative yes
uh this movie obviously is near and dear
to my heart yeah it's different yeah uh
guys uh all week I've been alluding to
the fact that it's been a dream of mine
to uh combine a few G fuel flavors and
so we warned you against that uh the
unfortunately the answer is it it turns
you into a well basically a half a
werewolf oh as you can see the lower
half of my face remains human it's like
a white wolf yeah I think it's more of a
what wolf uh what a werewolf magazine
call it werewolf magazine said
no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
please no
daddy oh god um production node uh it's
also having an effect on our microphones
or at least mine uh according to the
chat
sometimes
fine but uh we loved werewolf by night
so much we're going to be talking all
about it different implications for the
MCU give her moments we loved uh here
with me uh on this uh super special
episode we've got Brandon Barrick that's
right 57 confirmed kills that's right
I'm the Monster Hunter hide your moms
we've got uh Miss Mistoffelees uh
Jessica Clemens
The Who wolf himself Tony Victor hey
guys great to be here thanks to
everybody in the chat for supporting us
all week we couldn't do a show without
you guys you guys mean the world to me
and if you're listening on headphones
and you have your headphones turned all
the way up because you're gen Z and your
parents didn't teach you how to use
technology right and you put your
headphones on full volume turn them down
a little bit because today make it loud
oh might be some howls and then super
special guest Phil Molina is here freaky
Phillip Molino today I'm speaking very
quietly in case my mic is malfunctioning
currently but also it goes with my Ted
Bundy appearance you have some like
weird serial killer glasses over there
yeah Ted Bundy uh killed a girl at my
high school congratulations recently no
years before I went to that high school
but yeah he killed a girl in Lake City
Florida oh that's really neat anybody
else got some fun facts anyways
oh oh yeah we did it's true
um Brandon's friends with one that
killed his mom absolutely okay
scroll down on my Twitter and you'll
find the video
uh speaking of uh we're uh werewolf by
night today in the Super Chat once we
hit a hundred dollars in super chats and
every 100 after that in we will do a
Redemption where one of us uh who's not
Tommy who's already been transpired I
actually have a I actually can transform
oh okay okay if uh if need be if I am
voting upon uh I have I think figured
out the uh the way to turn myself back
oh okay well we'll find out uh but uh
one of us will transform into a rare
creature I don't know if it'll be a wolf
could be aware of something else you
know I'm reading the comments on the
teleprompter and it feels like you
avoided reading it the way it was
written sorry I'll I'll read it verbatim
here in one moment I know I know the who
wolf uh takes pride in his scripture
we're wearing our wear Transformations
wherever we're not wearing out our
welcome
100 one of us will transform the twist
yeah uh meanwhile the chat is pointing
out that what is on your faces in black
and white could be brown uh you brings
with some poopy brown streaks do I
something on my face
yeah yours is unrelated okay so I drew I
drew a dolphin okay so I think you
should have you should have just done it
wrong and see if they can sound okay
uh this would be if
he's changing
when are you gonna start doing the
dolphin bit wow
yeah you need a you need a silvery
Triton to take down that guy
um uh but first before we get into uh
further him into the Black Cove or
whatever that is oh geez Blackfin or
whatever black fish and planetary will
save me uh
let's do some headlines
yeah there they are oh a nice black and
white graphic uh I I just saw something
sorry real quick before we get to the
headlines I want to address a few things
in the chat the quiz master has been
apprehended again and is currently being
transported to gitmo so hopefully they
will can't hold them the quiz Master's
showing back up next Thursday and it's
gonna stir another round I pray to God
not I pray to God the real monsters live
among us and their names are quiz master
um in an interview with MTV News Mar
ghost Roby
of all kinds of great roles had this to
say about Lady Gaga taking over his
Harley Quinn and Joker too of course
that's a role she's made famous in
multiple uh films it makes me so happy
because I said from the very beginning
that all I want is for Holly Harley
Quinn to be one of those characters the
way Macbeth or Batman always gets passed
from great actor to Great actor nice
Margaret Robbie to include herself as a
great actor
um and and Lady Gaga uh it's such an
honor to have built a foundation strong
enough that Harley can now be one of
those characters that other actors get
to have a go at playing and I think
she'll do something incredible with it
Gaga
cursed no okay
turning into a car yeah
oh this is a really sad story now that
I'm imagining is it curse of sake I
think a werewolf got hit by a carless
by roadside
um discussing film learned that Craig
zobel is in talks to executive producer
director an undisclosed amount of
episodes for the HBO Max Batman spin-off
series The Penguin starring Colin
Farrell uh and Tommy and I were talking
about this Craig zobo has directed some
Westworld he's really respect left over
leftovers
water border ices at the Wawa that was a
Charming character the penguin in that
let's give them all spin-offs every
Saturday
spin off the commissioner who was great
on um the first commissioner was great
on uh uh and or right now yeah Linus
mosque yes uh yeah we all love that and
we want to see that world expand I mean
they've been talking about the spin-off
series for a while you know that man
came out a minute ago so I'm excited to
see those uh ironheart star Dominique
corn and Ryan coogler broke down her
debut in Black Panther wakanda forever
with Entertainment Weekly this week uh
uh they had this Thorne had this to say
I love the fact that she is just fully
herself she's definitely not the typical
or traditional superhero she's very much
Riri Williams the 19 year old student
first and then there's this whole
ironheart business that she has to
figure out
he's not happy about this rule oh the
iron heart is a business and business is
good
yeah but I like that right like uh if
we're looking for that kind of Peter
Parker model of superhero where they're
like a believable teenager first it's
dealing with all that kind of normal
stuff oh and then they also have this
obligation to be a superhero like
Riverdale
very like grounded Archie is like just
like us super grounded yeah
I don't think he can be burned he's like
I know I think why are they trying to
burn Archie uh my understanding is that
pretty much every week on Riverdale
starts with them trying to light our
Channel
my hair keeps getting into my own cup
yeah
yeah welcome to a cat life
um uh and then uh Ryan Cooper went on to
say I remember when Riri was invented in
publishing that's a fun way of saying it
invented and Publishing uh and there was
a level of excitement around her coming
up uh and he's of course Ryan coogler
director of both uh Black Panther films
is uh executive producing the ironheart
show uh it was similar to when Miles
Morales was invented having lived with
these archetypical uh characters for so
long it's always exciting seeing
somebody come up and take on the moniker
with a different background mom tell me
about the time I was invented in
publishing
it's time for mandatory
much like me this show can transform at
any time come on I think they're that
that makes me so nervous about you I
could call for mandatory fund whenever I
want because I'm The Wolf Man
remember the very famous Lon Chaney
werewolf that went
all right and tonight's gonna get munchy
uh all right he didn't even take a zoom
he says a lot of things he's he also has
short-term Amnesia so he can't remember
what he just said hit that graphic again
I just can't help myself
oh sorry John all right so today for
mandatory fun uh we're gonna do like
what I like to call little uh just quick
little burps of mandatory fun throughout
the episode we're gonna do pick up lines
for some famous monsters okay so we're
gonna have some some spookly Essentials
there's a moment there between uh Jack
Russell werewolf by night and Elsa
Bloodstone where he's kind of on top of
her and there's no chemistry of going
between us yeah so I want to say who
decided that was camping yeah
no when she has to like look him in the
eye to calm him down so he remembers if
it's her I don't know I don't know the
wolf was like I'm gonna have sex with
her I think the wolf was a wolf and it
was like oh
a human they started sniffing yeah
I really like that spoke to me remember
when we hired you guys oh yeah you guys
remember yeah yeah yeah yeah I was like
if you don't want me to attack you let
me smell you yeah it's like she's like
first things first and then a bit of a
sniff test yeah all right so we're gonna
do some pickup lines for some uh do some
spookly sensual statements first up
let's seduce Frankenstein you guys want
me to get us started out yeah give us a
Frankenstein hey Frank those are some
pretty nice bolts on your neck would you
like some nuts in your mouth
that was sweet spookily essential
Brandon wrote something I had to write
mine down so I can remember because I
get nervous when I'm in the presence of
a spooky thing this is for Frankenstein
hey you might be Frankenstein's monster
but I want to be Frankenstein's mounter
oh
uh uh I got one uh
a a Frankenstein
I heard you like bodybuilders
okay
uh Frankenstein more like Frank and lie
in bed with me
the only when they put you together the
only body part they were missing was my
dick
I was thinking you could go with
something like I don't care whose ass
that is I want to eat it
I'll transition this out of mandatory
fund by stealing one that Brandon said
earlier Frankenstein's monster you've
got me wetter than that little girl you
threw into the lake
I'm glad you took that one
I was about uh Eric didn't point it out
of the break in the breakdown but there
is a a moment at the very end of world
by night where there are some little
flowers I thought that was a reference
to Frankenstein because the little girl
by the water is plucking flowers
get him on the phone okay impossible we
need his number uh but does he have a
phone
spoke with marvel.com she broke down the
show's uh kind of hilarious fun take on
Daredevil's famous hallway fight scene
from the Netflix series and she uh had
this to say we have to keep reminding
people this is Jen show this is a
She-Hulk show everything in the show is
like how can we either
some Trope or Define tations
found something in funny reality that's
kind of the ethos of the show so of
course it was just natural for this show
being So Meta that we would acknowledge
and tease the classic Daredevil hallway
fight but then of course we would have
to undercut it with our girl She-Hulk
which I thought that was really fun when
he squares up against those that big
group of goons in the hallway I was like
oh we're about to get it and then yeah
right I was a little upset when she was
just throwing around random people's
cars and destroying a parking garage
you're worried about the property damage
yeah I thought that was pretty
interesting
in that world you have all-time jobs
when she does that clap and she takes
out Daredevil's hearing there could have
been an innocent bystander whose
eardrums would have been simply
destroyed yeah what about someone like
sleeping in their car yeah what about
someone who's like I just got Cochlear
implants and I can finally hear the
world again oh man
some of the people in the chat
complaining about our microphone it
happens maybe maybe they were uh Thunder
clapped first time putting headphones in
you simps
um speaking of werewolf by night uh and
speaking of Eric's breakdown he had a
couple interviews in his breakdown
definitely watch that it just came out
on the channel a few hours ago uh he
talks to the actress who played
um Elsa Bloodstone uh and he talked to
producer Brian Gay who um also spoke
with comicbook.com Brandon Davis uh kind
of mentioned why blade and Moon Knight
did not appear in the special uh and he
said we talked a little bit about blade
but in the end it was like you know what
if we're looking at this this and I
always describe this as an episode of
The Twilight Zone let's keep it
contained I know everyone searches for
connectivity we want this person in in
here and this and I was like no let's
just do this it exists in the same world
as all these other things but let's not
worry about that right now and I like
that right because if there are plenty
of Marvel uh greater greater use
references within werewolf by night
the blade it's a bigger characterized
Moon Knight would have kind of
distracted from the other girl for sure
right yeah yeah hey how do you pronounce
that director's name Michael guccino
giacchino I think that's how we're
sticking on it you know he does it
phonetically on his Twitter Michael
jokino is he still on stage uh
explaining how he got a green letter or
is that okay this is a reference to
yesterday uh uh off-screen dashel and
Jessica I got to go to a screening uh
I'm just more better writing where where
the director was there talking about it
we played a clip on the show yesterday
the clip was a little I think it's still
airing I think we're still live
streaming on a different okay how dare
you he's there to talk about his movie
he's allowed to talk about it as long as
anyone okay uh we did hit over a hundred
dollars in super chats that means
someone's gotta wear out for us I will
tell you thank you to J Masters
Wolverine as uh Steve starkum and
everybody that's throwing uh
I don't know that's a good question tell
us in the chat call in uh
from your from your Fez perfect through
your es huh I don't know from your past
okay to your Slavs Jessica
oh oh
that's commitment to character right
there uh well speaking of werewolf by
night if you go to new
rockstarsmerch.com you could check out a
new werewolf by a nice shirts
oh we got the graphic up there now this
shirt is also in black and white don't
let the don't let the the monochrome you
mean in real life in real life yes in
real life don't adjust your computer
monitors you are seeing that uh
correctly so check that out new
rockstarsmerge.com grab it right now
before it's gone it's metal as hell I
like that celebrate that celebrate that
that piece of clothing from your shirt
to your dirt
now submarine in the jet sand from your
horn to your candy corn oh
it's the Candy Corn
shape and size I can relate yes
no it certainly is one size well one of
the things we liked a lot about in
werewolf night was of course all the
monsters we got yeah but like are they
in the MCU were they here the whole time
you know we were kind of speculating
when that trailer came out that those
guards with the electric sticks they
looked very TVA yes it's very similar it
doesn't seem like they're in the TVA or
they certainly never call it out but
they also never really explain the
guards at all they're just kind of there
and nobody got pruned no one got did you
get shocked they were more like cattle
prods than they were like the pruning
sticks right right but they had cattle
yeah they had these like cattle prods
that keep everyone control but I could
have had this theory that like it would
make sense that we had the uh the MCU
the 616 and was being controlled by he
who remains we never had any monsters as
far as we know of of this kind of like
horror movie Monsters no vampires no
werewolves you hadn't seen any of that
before was that a factor of he who
remains keeping it out of the 616. right
was there something about monsters that
if they were running around loose that
makes it easier for a Kang to come in
and so part of because he who remains
the sacred timeline was all about like
keeping kangs out and now that he who
remains is dead thank you Sophie uh does
that mean that these monsters from
werewolf finite could now come in to the
616. and start appearing more is that
what we saw at the end of this uh a
special if you haven't finished it yet
when it starts to go to color does that
mean that they're now able to get in
because there's a lot of weird things in
this show so do we know specifically
that the color actually means something
uh well Zach was talking about an Eric's
breakdown he has his interview uh the
actress does address the color a little
bit but it seemed like no one in it
seemed like when Elsa has the stone and
the color starts to happen she doesn't
react dramatically no that is so
pleasant of you not from her point of
view yeah it's like the color was always
there in their world it's just as the
viewer we're now seeing the color but
but maybe that is they don't realize
that they're now part of a main timeline
right right so yeah I think like to
answer this we should talk about like
does this take place in our reality like
when does this take place where does
this take place do they do this cool job
of like we don't know where in the world
this is what year it is we don't know
when period well no we see some Graves
that say the 80s after the 80s right but
there's no cell phones there's no all
the music is from the 30s nobody
mentions who won the 2021 World Series
other than the electrical like cattle
prod anything else was like completely
electrical right all their weapons were
just like swords yeah they made a point
of like having old references now we
think that was mostly because they
wanted to reference all those great
Universal horror movies I think I mean I
don't think those cattle stunners
existed in that form of that violence
yeah those were very intense well and
even just the guards themselves yeah
they were dressed we're not like they're
wearing Keystone Cops you know they were
modern reanimated corpse of Ulysses
Bloodstone was cranking gear
do not forget to please Google cogsworth
destroys Miss minutes this week
uh was was talking about the gears
getting smashed no was Ulysses
Bloodstone a crank yanker I don't know
uh but yeah when does the if if this if
this does exist in some sort of weird
side pocket reality because we know in
the Loki series uh uh Mobius mentions
that they've dealt with vampires yeah
they have dealt with it so if they are
dealing with vampires were they busy
pruning vampires out of the 616 to keep
them out but I'm confused why you think
Dev monsters aren't part of the greater
plan in fact that's a little racist I
guess I mean that is very presumptuous
of me uh check my privilege at the door
I'm not a monster uh but most are people
I would think by now in over 30 Films
from the MCU if especially like the
stuff with the Mystic Arts a vampire
might have come up by this point if
they're if they are prolific enough they
might be there all at all times well and
you know one thing I was even
speculating about right we see the the
Bloodstone family this Bloodstone Club
of Monster Hunters right like they're
all pretty successful they add up to
over 200 kills amongst them or whatever
and they all get wiped out so is there
also something like these people were
the ones getting the monster they would
hunt it over there into Oblivion but now
that they're all gone oh now monsters
like man thing and werewolf By Night can
kind of Thrive right that feels uh
definitely like what they're going
forward it's like this is why they
weren't here before is because they had
all these people because the holder of
the Bloodstone was always hunting down
monsters and no it doesn't seem like
that's really Elsa's idea right she
mostly just wants that for to keep it
out of other people's hands she's got
that interested in hunting down monsters
it had some like shangshi Vibes at the
end of like now I'm taking over this
organization and things are going to be
a little different around here this
ain't your daddy's Bloodstone Monsters
uh monster emotion thus ain't divided
that okay are you okay
werewolf having a stroke live on air
yeah
white wolf right there
but with blade coming we know there's
going to be more of this yeah kind of
dark side of the MCU the horror side
maybe Kevin of chaos might have some
more of this yes
I mean the violence of this people yeah
the graphic sword getting stuck in game
yeah yeah so what kind of twist what's
your pitch for like the next big monster
feature appearance Monster Squad get out
of here
Wolfman Scott
I was gonna say it feels like we're
getting we got this around Halloween
we're getting Guardians of the Galaxy
holiday special around Christmas
doesn't it feel like every Halloween we
can get some one-off Marvel special It
won't always it could be I mean it could
wouldn't be close we're off by night
every year yeah for like the next two or
three werewolves and man thing just
camping yeah I mean then we're going on
different Adventures or having a battle
different things or like they could
cycle through some of the other again
Dracula as a character my dinner with
man thing at the sushi restaurant oh no
they'd have to catch up because it's
like okay next year we'll do another
horror thing but then once blade comes
out or another horror property a
Harkness the coven yeah
but I think it's like oh they have to
catch up so they're gonna have to take
like less prominent characters
um in order to do that which is fine I
mean she holds doing it yeah and kind of
dig deeper into the obviously there's so
many like kind of monstery villains yeah
that they could kind of re-uh uh pitch
as you know interesting characters for a
one-off special and these are great for
more street level heroes right it's a
problem for a town because really of the
monster the main monster groups that we
know of the vampires are the most
dangerous I think because they're the
ones able to spread it quickly like a
mummy doesn't necessarily make more
mummies Mommy's got a curse you deal
with that uh Frankenstein doesn't make
more Frankensteins yeah but the vampires
could spread like a virus a whole season
of a show the upcoming Daredevil count
chocula yeah
blueberry well unless we forget in the
comic books post M day uh Michael
Jubilee she's a vampire now bringing
Jubilee as the vampire let's go where's
Jubilation Sparkles uh no she
unfortunately was the only major uh uh
immune and I know she was the the only
really major mainstream mutant to Loser
powers for real a lot of mutants lost
their powers on them day half of them
were just like oh I just have PTSD and
they got their powers back so depressing
they did my girl Jubilee like um
dressing up as Jubilee dressed up save
yeah that would that would raise my
spirit just mentioned the mummy
um Tommy did you have some plans some
maybe mummy de Tory fun man it's always
fun oh my gosh wait wait before we do
mandatory fun done
I need to do a role play with you for
this one so can you come over here don't
make John come here
this is a trick John don't don't come
over here John you you're like nothing
again
all right
wow
we're gonna hit on directly you're gonna
be Dracula for this one okay okay oh
John's gonna be drafted yeah hey let me
check my notes hey Dracula you like
sleeping in a coffin how would you like
to be coughing on my nuts in your mouth
hey hey Dracula I'm gonna take my steak
and drive it through your part and then
butt cheeks
hey Dracula hey baby hey I heard you
only come at night get with me and
you'll come all day too oh my God again
the premise of this is we are doing
Monster pickup lines uh it's recurring
throughout the show if you're just
joining us hey Dracula I'm down for a
little Fang bang if you don't talk about
it hey Dracula heard you like to suck
penis
you can turn into a bat right do you
want to bat around my nuts
did Tommy already say uh Dracula I'll
drag my nuts of questions
it's jugular
hey when you're done with with me you
won't be able to look at yourself in the
mirror
on it they're less pickup lines and more
sexual harassment
I know you hate garlic but would you
hate to garlic these nuts
hey Dracula I hear you you're Immortal
well I'll be done with you in less than
30 seconds yeah
uh hang on let me try that again hey hey
hey hey Dracula
hey Dracula hey you want to go into uh
my van and uh helsink hey hey Dracula
hey drunk you wanna hang out and uh
leave me with uh two bloody holes
I heard you can fly why don't you fly
that mouth over to these nuts
put them in your mouth
okay uh TD Jones thank you sir uh
everybody in the Super Chat we want to
take a quick I told my mom she had to
watch this episode today for the sketch
this shot I just remember to cut it off
we want to shout out our good friends at
G fuel for sponsoring the break rooms
aren't watching not endorsing any of
what we did yeah
reputable and and we did a fun sketch at
the beginning where Tommy was converted
into a werewolf by mixing different G
fuel flavors uh that is not what will
happen to you it's kind of like how Jen
Walters turns into She-Hulk but she's a
special thing in her blood only uh
specific bechtolds in the back told line
yes will be converted into werewolves if
they mix G fuel flavors right um we've
got we've been drinking actually I'm
drinking it right now uh unstable portal
fluid flavor uh all week long which is
their Rick and Morty flavor very good
it's very good it's like a strawberry
lemonade flavor but they've got
truly a bunch of flavors we we got cans
all around the office we enjoy them the
cool thing about g-fuel they've got a
bunch of energy flavors where it's just
like an energy drink to get you boosted
and focused they've got a bunch of
hydration flavors we're just like hey
you want something that don't taste like
water but uh also doesn't have sugar or
caffeine or anything else that's got a
bunch of vitamins aminos and stuff like
that I got some Halloween ones yeah they
do they've got Hocus Focus which is
whoever named that deserves a raise over
at G Fuel and they've got a candy corn
pumpkin bundle from your horn to your
candy corn I love a pumpkin bundle hey
Dracula
[Laughter]
for sponsoring us all week long uh if
you want to stock up maybe you already
have some you've done g-fuel in the past
but if you want to try it out use the
link in our description and use the
promo code new rockstars you get 30 off
your order whatever you're buying a g
fuel whether it's the unstable portal
fluid flavor or something else and we uh
uh get to keep being supported by G Fuel
and we keep bringing this show to you in
beautiful black and white uh real quick
Zack before we move on I I have
discovered the formula to turn myself
back and it does involve G fuel okay so
I'm thinking if you guys can bear with
me here for a second yeah I want to give
myself a chance
this is ironic where somebody else has
to turn into a different wear cream yeah
we did cross uh across our Redemption
okay so this timing actually works I'm
down let's do it so okay oh Phillips
came hope you do it while I prep okay
used to that all right
all right I like that joke all right
oh no guys it's just I don't know are
you okay
oh oh it's getting taller
oh hey
it's very teeth specific is he a
wardrobe where giraffe yeah make a noise
of your animal maybe all right uh and
that's not an animal oh maybe is it a
horse
somebody give this guy an apple
what happens
oh God okay there you go so far nothing
is your heart okay I thought you just
peed yourself
oh oh he's changing
oh no hold on guys let alone do it okay
oh now he's he's crawling oh his bones
are reshaped oh my gosh I think he's
taking his clothes off again I think
he's it's like something has shifted
inside of him no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no he's gone too far
he's converting into something else
it fits too well in the form of a bag of
sometimes oh my God
hey you guys what's up oh my God I'm
from New Jersey oh are you wearing a
trash bag oh no this is the official
shirt of people from New Jersey oh
j-e-t-s Jets Jets Jets zombies turned
into a New Jersey I'm gonna go get a
froyo down at Mulligan's on Church
Street then I'm gonna kiss my wife on
the lips with no tongue cause we haven't
had sex in 12 years you know some people
have marriages that are either okay
where's the best slice of pizza in your
hometown
you're from East Rutherford yes it's not
as good as Gino's on Main Street the
best slice of pie ever everything I do
is the best ever you know no one else
has ever done better than me cause I'm
from New Jersey how do we transform this
like 50 of this yeah yeah I don't know
any other things I'm 100 the highest
grade I ever got on a test was 40 so 100
is a very special number to me I'm from
Newton you can't tell me okay I don't
think we might need to shotgun another
I'm dressed as a cat wow
um my mom is a rat okay let's just tell
me we wouldn't do it real quick one
other thing about um werewolf by night
any other thoughts favorite moments
other elements that we didn't get to
talk about the the transformation scene
right yeah uh second only two when Tommy
turned back into the day I met him uh
damn that like Shadow based one that was
like all practical and just like focused
on her face I love that I love that it
just got into it there was not much
preamble to it it really rolled right
into it and man that ending was really
beautiful the color the color choices it
had the kind of vintage feel to it it's
beautiful man thing in full color looked
great so good and I liked when you saw
him the way he moved was very like Harry
hasn't stopped motion uh King Kong like
Old King kong-esque like they can make
it look smoother but they purposely made
it look a little like monster movie they
might have even dropped some frames yeah
yeah which I really really liked I mean
everyone was great in it it was just
like so much fun so different so violent
a little funny in the right way yeah you
know what that was pretty into very
aware of it yeah the um I can't remember
her name was it Ursula or something like
that the the stepmother character was so
kind of campy and the best possible you
know Bride of Frankenstein kind of away
she had me feeling some type of way that
ocean uh speaking of ursulas I love a
sea witch says I think little mermaid is
real okay
you can't get into that very much
somebody called This is Bernie Sanders
does anyone ever been to Pinocchio's
Playhouse it's a strip club but they
make a great chicken parmesan my nose
ain't the only thing growing at
Pinocchio's I'm from New Jersey
I also loved the uh the Marvel intro in
like a minor key with like the choir
like that was so fun
yeah I love how much they've been
playing around with that like I wish uh
in the I am Groot series how he fast
forwards every time I wish they would
put that into Disney plus that you could
just do that because I love the opening
crop but sometimes when you re-watch
they'll be like yeah let's skip this it
is a little weird on She-Hulk where it's
like a fun little sitcom yeah
let's get through it let's get through
it I think um Eric did a good job in his
breakdown of pointing out the different
musical cues obviously Michael giacino
is a composer yeah
yeah but also I mean we met him back on
lost so many movies he's worked on TV
shows from there and Game of Thrones I
believe he did work yes I'm pretty sure
everybody by the way best yes you did uh
no way in like 411 Thunder but like I
love the specific old music songs that
he picked obviously uh Somewhere Over
the Rainbow at the end is like really
well known but the other ones are a
little bit more obscure and I like that
you know Somewhere Over the Rainbow was
so bizarre to me because it was like oh
this is like what Disney I don't think
they own they actually had to go out and
get it buy a new song famously MGM yeah
uh property yeah which so often like
ever since the moment like Disney bought
uh Marvel there was all of a sudden like
Disney references everywhere like that
was right before Age of Ultron I think
and in Age of Ultron he does the like
I've got no strings and it was like oh
now that they have this like catalog of
Disney stuff that they can reference uh
they do it all the time now and it's
great do you guys feel like you saw any
he's a composer first we all know him
that way do you feel like you saw that
in his directing at all like how he
approached his piece I mean definitely
the fight sequence right was really fit
with the music and kind of time to it in
an interesting way uh I felt I don't
know this to the flaming tuba he's just
so weird and besides but I feel like
that's something a composer he would
have he probably was doing the thing
where that the word diegetic right it
means that the sound is coming from the
story so we can see right he probably
would have scored that to be in there
and it was like well now I come back
it did have a lot of right we saw the
gramophone there was a lot of diegetic
music throughout the piece that's a good
point I hadn't even thought of that
um well one thing like it's very clear
he loves those old movies there's so
many like visual motifs from the old
horror movies I really wish like like uh
off screen Dash will got to see it in a
movie theater you know I watch it on my
home TV I wonder like how that sound and
some of those fight scenes would have
played on a big screen there are doing
some new Beverly's doing the screening
free popcorn and soda hey I call it pop
I like this version of the Jersey game
yeah my hero by the situation says GT
out gentam laundry I say GTL gin tonic
and loneliness I'm from New Jersey we
should call out some of our super chats
we've gotten today
uh film just saying uh Zach you may have
drawn first blood but I will draw first
booed oh terrible I cursed myself as I
said Austin long pointing out imagine
your boss coming in just to eat the only
mic on the table unbelievable yep
unbelievable you don't have to imagine
how dare you how dare you uh you caprita
looking for all the Easter eggs in that
intro good luck you're gonna have to get
a magnet uh yeah uh Eric wants to do a
breakdown of our cold open at some point
uh Steven starkham Stephen starkham
saying I'm team vampire but I owe you
guys so much money for all the times
you've distracted me from The Real World
now wolf out please do breakdowns for an
interview with the Vampire and AMC plus
I'll love you forever I've heard that
shows I very much enjoyed it very much
enjoyed the pilot okay they got a gray
worm from okay
okay I don't know that I don't know that
it's quite popular enough for us to
cover it but let us I mean hey if a lot
of people demand it we might we might
need the season and dip into it also a
Christian unpronounceable uh good friend
of the show there uh will you guys
change back to color for the end of the
episode it's on the budget I don't know
if that's possible also I don't know
that this Show's gonna have a happy
ending so if I can say this all of my
shows end with a happy ending uh I think
interview vampire uh it was a vampire's
worth watching and I promised it from my
blood sucker dude my tiny Pucker
[Applause]
GT pointing out mandatory fun is not
bound by the laws of time that's right
that's right it's time for mandatory
for that to happen that's right it's the
actual time in the show where we do
mandatory fun where I gather four of my
best friends in the whole world together
for a little bit of fun with me today
we've been doing pickup lines for famous
monsters since it's now the official
segment we're gonna do a twofer we're
gonna go first we're gonna go with the
mummy so for instance I would say hey
The Mummy check my notes I hear you're
wrapped up how about you wrap your mouth
around my nuts
um I'm gonna say uh mummy more like
Mommy because I'm trying to suck on that
too
I'm gonna say uh to The Mummy when it
comes to taking that dead dick I'm not
Scarab
oh that's gross that's gross and I don't
know I love it I'm gonna run into mommy
I'm gonna say I'm gonna be up in them
guts Like An Egyptian mummy maker
just like the mummy when I die I hope
I'm surrounded by [ __ ]
hey I heard you like a good uh
sarcophagus well this one has no gag
reflex oh my gosh about uh hey hey mummy
uh after you're hooking up with me the
only curse you'll get is Hepatitis C
yeah
piggybacking on Phillips uh Hey mummy I
heard you like a good sarcophagus why
don't you scarf the esophagus on these
nuts coming back to zags hey mummy when
you're done with me you can clean
yourself up because
hey Mommy I'd like to be bound and
gagged as well
hey hey mummy underneath my clothes I'm
also just a sack of Bones hey mummy am I
a sick freaking bed yes I am I have
mummy issues that's a good idea okay
all right moving on casually to the
second part of mandatory fun
we are going to hit on not a universal
monster but a monster that I've always
had a personal attraction to
uh Medusa oh oh real quick so Wolverine
did have in the chat before you smack it
let me wrap it that's a pretty good
mummy one question
okay I thought maybe you get a nosebleed
I gotta take it on on Medusa before
anybody else
the more I look at you the harder I get
yeah yeah I can put another snake in
your head
hey that's a really good one you got a
bunch of snakes in your hair how about
two snake eggs in your mouth
I know I know
you missed it Tommy because what it
should have been is like hey Medusa I'd
like you to introduce I'd like to
introduce you to Jason and his Argan
nuts
I was gonna say I was gonna say when it
comes to Medusa I'd be getting more head
than Hercules
Chrissy in the chat who knows our
mythology the only girl that oh you guys
already said this the only girl they can
get me bricked up and stoned
I do so I'm not afraid of a cloaca I
know
[Applause]
don't mind if me do so hey hey Medusa if
there's mirrors in the yard you know I'm
going hard
hey Medusa no eye contact and we only
got to hit it from the back it sounds
like a back told Revelation I'm from
Jersey
[Laughter]
not anymore they're just sorry the mix
asking no end credit scene it's true
there is no post credit or is he asking
about this show I mean this show
yeah nothing in uh where would my knight
to those credits roll there are some
cool kind of fun uh artistic Graphics
yeah during the credits but no we do it
we do have HR just off screen with
Electro sticks ready to take us off
I didn't like how fast Patty walked by
the show this time yeah
uh Carlos vizan how did man thing get
there from sakar have we was there a
reference demand thing on sakar in uh uh
Thor Ragnarok he's not on the he's not
one of the heads on the building is yeah
well I didn't I don't I don't know that
maybe that's a deep a deep that might be
something from the comics baby
I don't want to get in your sarcophagus
I want to ruin your oh okay I get it
that was a good one you guys are funnier
than us in the chat yeah but don't don't
give up that much better that far yeah
me Leia did point out Jessica that you
nailed it what nailed it you're
conversion into a weird camera yes a lot
of people a lot of people have nice
stuff to say about Phillips uh warehorse
as well yeah
um this is on the state flag of New
Jersey we're about 18 away from a third
where uh transformation who knows if
we'll see that we only got a couple
minutes left
oh free girl
um uh hey oh hey oh you wait hey all you
wear horse hosts guys since it looks
like we are going to get Midnight Suns
yeah we already got a couple memories of
it who do you think will be in the
lineup and why will Elsa Bloodstone be
the cheeky one I mean she's the cheeky
one for sure we all loved that action
fun characters
um yeah so I mean midnight says there's
been a bunch of people in the in
different Comics runs a ghost writer
often is a member of the midnight Sons I
mean obviously like you know having
blade
but I think now
saracen uh like man thing has got to be
there I mean like this is the baby Yoda
moment for uh for Marvel right now I
would buy it you are more man thing baby
okay and what a smart move to make him a
gentle giant with acid hands when I
watched it I was like if they kill him I
swear to God I was like that was like my
first reaction I had was like a baby
Yoda saying I also like he's like a um
he's like a a smart gun or something
like that in that he can only really
harm people that mean to do him yeah
yeah right he'll only hurt you if you're
coming at him yeah
on emotions yeah yeah so if you're if
you're there that's why he said you know
uh when um Jack Russell uh pre werewolf
tells Elsa Bloodstone like treat him
like an old friend yeah and he won't
hurt Ted right yeah
okay that is my name
I want him to have Scooby's voice Roma
later this afternoon look for uh
Jessica's She-Hulk breakdown for episode
eight and like we said Eric's breakdown
for World by night is already up on the
channel he's got some great interviews
I've been to people in the comments
demanding a Mario trailer oh I'll do it
I'll do it well someone already did yeah
keep an eye out keep an eye out on the
channel I thought I was in prison no no
Anna's never broken a law the quiz
Master is I have to break several every
night that's a good point you guys keep
letting them on which is insane to me oh
Zach I think it's your turn to transform
them oh no okay take us out on a
transformation oh god oh no
oh no oh oh oh no
[Music]
what are you oh uh
how many teats did you grab as you
worked your way up your body yeah are
you squirting I think they're squirting
yeah
[Applause]
[Applause]
how about you graze on my nuts in your
mouth I'm not even a monster hey hey hey
we're Cal I heard you got four stomachs
would you like to fill them with four of
my nuts four of your nuts hey hey I
can't fight it our apologies to and door
special guest uh this week that was
gonna be on the show we did not have
time unfortunately we are sorry
someone someone said he's turning into
me in college
and by the way Diego Luna how about I
Diego Lona my nuts oh my God
and bring your real life buddies Diego
Luna and Gabriel Garcia Bernal yeah like
real life friends and if you know simulu
please bring them on the show
go watch this episode when you try and
see what the vibe now tell your your
agents and managers and your handlers at
Marvel that we will be on our best
behavior when you come on the show we
will never say when you're on the show
uh hey wolf man
um
want to see my full moon
yeah yeah all right and by the way uh
everybody in New Jersey we're thinking
about you there's nothing wrong going on
with your state right now I just assume
all of you are in Peril at all times
this is always the hate Community always
the hate for New Jersey
um all right thank you everybody if you
made it oh are we off
no okay we're still on here FCC can't
stop us yet
he's Transformers
oh no there's that weird other part of
the liner again
and now he's better hey if you made it
this far in the episode you appreciate
kind of the strange production value and
weird Concepts we put into the show hit
like come back we're gonna we're gonna
be doing a lot of fun Halloween themed
episodes throughout this month yeah
there will be some other fun costumes
throughout the month we'll be doing big
episodes around so things like the Black
Adam release there's gonna be so much uh
what kind of forever fun content on this
show and on new rockstars in general
definitely like subscribe and come back
and hang out with us yeah like the like
the show subscribe to the channel uh um
Tommy prime minister you do to end the
show he'd do some fun pickup lines for
one final monster and that's Shrek oh
that's a good one Shrek your best friend
married a dragon how about I drag my
nuts from your belly button to your
mouse how about you get up in this one
you say ogres are like onions how about
a couple pearl onions in your mouth
[Music]
Dazzle almost walked away from the
camera you sickened my cameraman hey uh
Hey Shrek I know you know Puss in Boots
do you know nothing mouth
[Laughter]
I'm gonna grab those little tenant right
you like a bike baby
no no joke this is just side note my
gamertag is writing trick
look her up on PSN folks riding Shrek
check her out on Steve
all right thank you all so much thank
you Phillip Molina for joining us
we'll see you guys here next week
have a great weekend later skaters
ladies and gentlemen
[Music]
[Music]